at the Vatican it is a day of mourning
for Pope Benedict XVI who died Saturday
at age 95. thousands filed past the pope
Emeritus body as it lay in state at St
Peter's Basilica he'll be buried by his
successor Pope Francis on Thursday Chris
livesay is in Rome Chris good morning
good morning Adriana I've just been to
see the body of Pope Benedict lying in
state as are the thousands of people
lining up behind me at Saint Peter's
Basilica he's wearing red and gold
vestments flanked on both sides by Swiss
guards there's organ music playing also
solemn singing It's precisely the type
of setting you would expect for a papacy
marked by his Orthodoxy but not without
his contradictions
he was known as a traditionalist God's
rottweiler for fiercely adhering to
church doctrine but Benedict's papacy
was a papacy of Firsts despite his
failures during a 2008 trip to the U.S
he was the first pope to meet with
victims of sex abuse and to publicly
apologize condemning what he called
filth in the church and in his most
defining act Benedict was the first pope
to resign in six centuries recognizing
he said his incapacity to fulfill his
ministry due to the strain of old age
while he made a majestic farewell over
the Eternal City in his exit from the
papacy he never exited the Vatican while
France's championed Benedict's bravery
to abdicate his power having two men
wearing white created the impression of
two competing ideological camps Francis
the more liberal Benedict the arch
conservative it was a mistake to step
down says Tina white from Detroit it's
an amazing
honor to be elected Pope and you
shouldn't throw that away but now for
the first time since he became Pope in
2013 Francis is finally the only one now
mourning his only Confidant who could
possibly understand what it meant to be
Pope says Jerry O'Connell Vatican expert
for America magazine what does Francis
lose with the death of Benedict Francis
has always been attracted to
grandparents and he's always referred to
grandparents as very important in the
life of the family he has lost
grandfather
and on Thursday it will be Francis
making history becoming the first pope
in modern times to preside over the
funeral of his predecessor we're told by
the Vatican it will be a simple and
somber Affair exactly how Benedict
wanted Adriana
Chris let's say in Rome thank you